[Music]
for the next door you Rick and Morty
Rick Sanchez you son of a [ __ ] needs
some people for a thing large pose I had
a job that didn't care if you've done
time or whatever's going on with your
confusing ass hands in hey truculent
you son of a [ __ ] I mean
thanks for doing this guys what's the
job that was it
by the toilet episode is just an
exploration of Rick's isolation starting
with something a lot of people can
relate to which is being a shy pooper
here's a secret pooping places then
somebody had the idea that what if he
goes there and somebody else in there we
were off to the races
poop with me Tony poop with me the thing
that I love is showing how lonely Rick
is and then his rejection of friendship
from someone who really is like a good
person you're not gonna kill me don't
tell me what to do you know Rick starts
out thinking that Tony's just another
individual he's gonna have to kill or
bully to get what he wants and he's
surprised by Tony's fearlessness what it
turns into a story about Rick's capacity
for friendship I have a million cooler
friends than you I'll be seeing you I
think also just the shock of this person
dying it just kind of I think it further
cements Rick as this lonely person who's
never gonna get close to anybody
you know it's like why bother there he
is there's our guy long live the big
catch a new episode Sunday at 11:30 only
I'm Adult Swim welcome back everyone
it's Charlie this is gonna be my Rick
and Morty season 4 episode 3 trailer
video there's a whole bunch of Easter
eggs I'm doing videos for all the
episodes this season if you're new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get
everything we're even doing a weekly
merch giveaway so the episode is titled
one crew over the crew coos Morty
obviously a reference to One Flew Over
the Cuckoo's Nest and the Ocean's eleven
montage of Rick putting together a team
for what initially seems like a heist he
might want to pull off in this space
casino with the giant big vault behind
them the official episode descriptions
that they released a while ago are
pretty terrible it just reads a lot of
twists and turns this time bro wear your
helmets most of the characters he
assembles for his team are parodies of
Ocean's eleven characters or science
fiction movie characters like this one
he goes to pick up at the club is a
parody of the Livingston character from
Ocean's Twelve after that first Ocean's
eleven movie this excessively robbed the
casinos in the first movie but instead
of spending all of his money when they
picked up in the second movie he was
failing badly at trying to be a stand-up
comedian in tiny bars and living with
his mother not spending any of the
millions that they had stolen the second
one is a parody of a Lita battle angel
with all the crazy cyborg parts that
separate into a billion different pieces
I'm assuming Rick is supposed to be the
George Clooney character in this version
of Ocean's eleven the truculent joke is
a combination of a couple different bits
and references to previous episodes of
Rick and Morty on the surface it's a
reference to Scott Caan and Casey
Affleck scare ik ters from ocean's 11
who are running a car racing track when
George Clooney's character found them
it's also Ryan Ridley doing the voice of
a driver and he's kind of doing a
vampire Dracula bit is that his name is
truculence vampire looking truck but
he's also a real vampire which seems
like a violation of the tiny rig
post-credit scene where the head vampire
was really upset because the PE teacher
that was secretly a vampire it's summer
and Morty's school was using a vampire
bit name no more bits just use a regular
name next time and the person voicing
that vampire was also Ryan Ridley no
more of this clever name [ __ ] when a
vampire's betaine
be human they can just call themselves
Alan Jefferson or something like that
they do these weird scene transitions
like they did in Ocean's eleven Morty
has his backpack with him then after
Rick assembles his crew they show up
inside the space casino looking building
all wearing special name tags but the
print is too small and blurry to read
what it actually says but they're
waiting for Rick's orders like they're
building to some epic Ocean's eleven
heist and when they asked what the
actual job is Richards completely throws
the bid away saying that was it and they
just walks away like this is supposed to
be a cold open joke that's not really
connected to the actual plot of the
episode like Rick Lantis mix up when
they totally mislead you in the opening
scene about what the episodes story
actually is and then they follow the
Citadel of Rick's where this is a long
bit from later in the episode and
richest needs this crew for show they do
that every once in a while on Rick and
Morty super elaborate mr. X and throw
away gags that go nowhere like some of
the bits from interdimensional cable
that's just the writers riffing on jokes
that don't really have anything to do
with something that Rick and Morty are
trying to achieve or steal during an
episode or the Roy game from blitz and
chips you spend all this time in the
simulation doing a complete Ark on Roy's
life and then when they rip the helmet
off
Morty is so confused he still isn't
quite sure if he's Roy or if he's Morty
and he was just playing a VR game the
way they animated and told that story
made it seem like it was a real arc that
was playing out and he was a real person
you also might recognize a bunch of
trailer scenes from the season 4 trailer
with them at a heist convention there
was the Doctor Strange joke with his
intelligent lab coat strangling this guy
there were the scenes of them stealing
this spaceship from the aliens who
themselves are stealing bits of this
building here so because of the Ocean's
eleven theme title in sequence here the
whole episode might just be parodies of
heist movie tropes with Rick just
wanting some small thing that winds up
not being that big a deal at the end of
the day like when they sent Morty and a
bird off link ler on that epic mission
to get those crystals making it seem
like they were critical for some a
life-saving adventure which we then
found out we're just for partying so
they could crush up and snort them and
do his little dance but they did this
whole long misdirect bit about this
relationship between a bird off winkler
his death in this huge moment in trying
to atone for something with Rick turns
out nope complete misdirect speaking of
which I know a bird off link
we're still alive at the end of that
episode people wondering if he'd ever
come back he was such a weird character
I'm not expecting to see him again
though then they took all about Rick
isolating himself in last week's episode
I totally buy all the things they say
about that and Justin talking about how
lonely he is they've done that a couple
times before like at the end of the
unity episode where he almost
successfully ended all the versions of
himself across the multiverse completely
if you never listen to the commentary on
that episode they actually say that what
he's doing here this special fluid was
supposed to sink all the different
versions of himself across the
multiverse so that when this laser
device would have destroyed our c-137
Rick right here it would have also
killed every other single Rick in all of
existence but he's so wasted the joke is
that he passes out and the beam misses
his head the WTF moment there was that
he actually tried to do it they also
kind of follow up on that again the idea
of Rick being super lonely at the end of
season two when he realizes he has to
turn himself in this grim if not
temporary acceptance of his fate it
didn't stick because right after this
you have the events of season 3 episode
1 where he escapes Galactic prison so
even though they do have downer endings
sometimes they're usually really quick
to take that stuff back but I do think
it's funny when Justin talks about how
quick Rick is to reject the idea of true
friendship despite the fact that he's so
lonely the difference with season 4
episode 2 is that they leave on a downer
ending instead of taking it right back
with some sort of post-credit scene more
like the end of episode 1 with Rick and
Morty being all optimistic and excited
for their future adventures there were
also a lot of you that asked about
Rick's wife on my episode 2 video asking
if I thought that this woman next to
Tony in the red fluid sacks was Rick's
wife c-137 Rick's wife in there a couple
reasons why I don't think that it's her
number one the woman does have blonde
hair like Rick's wife but if you look at
her eyes she's got little bugged out
alien eyes meaning that she's probably
not human and as cool as it would be to
think that Beth was secretly part alien
I don't think that Rick's wife was an
alien too I don't think that Dan and
Justin would be so quick to reveal
Rick's wife after spending so many
seasons saying that they never really
cared to explain what happened about her
no joke when you go back and you listen
to people asking them questions about
her in previous seasons typically their
answer is we
don't know or we haven't talked about
what happened to Rick's wife or where
she might be if she's alive because we
don't think that answering that question
is interesting so the writers including
Dan and Justin just clearly have no
interest in explaining what really did
happen to her and if they ever did tease
his wife again it would probably be some
other fake-out reference that wouldn't
require them to commit to a story like
they wouldn't want to nail themselves
into a corner on what really happened to
her like during season 3 episode 1 in
that flashback they tell you this big
elaborate story that seems real but the
twist is is that Rick maybe made the
whole thing up Justin has said in the
past and I think he says it on the
commentary
there's always elements of truth in
every lie so aspects of this backstory
might have really happened in probably
the biggest reason why I don't think
this is Rick's wife is because they just
got a 70 episode order a while ago I
don't think they would tip their hand on
something as big as Rick's wife right
away at the beginning of that if they
ever did decide they wanted to show her
again maybe it would be after a couple
years when they run out of other really
interesting ideas but let me know in the
comments what do you actually think
happened to Rick's wife is she dead or
is she just out there somewhere in the
multiverse and if you spotted any Easter
eggs in these trailers that I didn't
mention in the video just write them
below in the comments I will do another
Rick and Morty bonus video later this
week there's a whole bunch of stuff
coming up every one click here for my
Rick and Morty season 4 episode 2 video
and click here for my Rick and Morty
season 4 episode 1 video thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]